everybody looks so great today okay
perfect i want to get straight to the
vffs because
i'm wondering you guys if we could do a
social experiment
all right i have never watched the
bachelor before or the bachelorette
um so i'm a newbie and
i really want to watch this season with
people
is anyone in the wall vffs any bachelor
bachelorette fans anybody watching
yes have you seen this
i love the bachelorette you do
okay great now what
allison is what do you love about it
well what i love about this season is
that
she's older and she knows what she wants
she's playing no games okay
so and her name is claire and she's been
on a few other seasons
she has i love that you know we've all
come along with her on this journey
and i'm hoping she finds love this
season which it seems like
it's probable although it seems like
there's a bunch of shenanigans coming up
around the corner
here's the one thing i took from the
bachelor and maybe it's just a first
episode like intro i felt like i was
watching for seven
hours and we did covet claire the host
and the first limo hadn't pulled up yet
and i was like am i on a hallucinogenic
because
i am convinced it's claire covet and the
host like that's all that's discussed
so i'm ready for more action
but i think there's going to be way more
action
well it seems like there's a bunch of
drama coming up with dale
and like an episode okay so the next
episode is tonight so
let's discuss it tomorrow if everybody
would
raise your hands if you're a fan of the
bachelor in the bffs
yes okay great all right all right well
i want to join in on the fun
[Music]
you